I think that's so inspiring your whole
story and I know and everybody else does
it so talk everybody through it let's
talk about your stroke like when that
happened so I'm legally obligated to
explain I'm not a doctor I've just
played one on TV but my specific stroke
happened it's very glamorous I was in a
film festival in Florida I had a
premiere of a movie I had just done and
after winning Best Supporting Actor
thanks humblebrag I was in the men's
room at the Tampa Airport I'd wondered
and I just suddenly next thing I know is
on the floor like out of nowhere
Nora I was I had a bottle of water I was
trying to screw the cap back on until
the my left hand wasn't working it
sounds like that's weird like it just
comes like ah listen and then my leg my
left leg went off from honoré he's crazy
like out of nowhere out of nowhere I'd
had a really bad headache the night
before which I've now learned that if he
ever had the worst headache your life
you've got a lot you go to the emergency
room but no one would know that because
people get migraines so you never know
but yeah but um somehow these gentlemen
in the men's room decided I wasn't
either drunk or on drugs and the dryer
to think Thank You guys whoever you are
neither Caird me or dragging me out of
the bathroom put me in the waiting area
on a bench kind of like this with no arm
here so I could sliding out this because
I was about to get on a plane to fly
back to LA and I but I knew my flight
was over there so I kept trying to get
up and walk that way my leg just kept
going on about 12 times in it you know
that's incredibly scary like just to not
know what's happening that that would
scare me to death I don't know how you
did that but the most amazing part was
actually you and there ended up being a
roll and this is us that they based off
of your real-life experience
right yes yeah sooo Dan Fogelman who's
the creator of that shell also created
another TV show and called galavant and
he'd been keeping tabs on me in my
recovery process mm-hmm and text me what
Danis like I think I got something for
you
I'm thinking about writing a guy who's
deep and recovered from a stroke yeah it
was like Sam yet man and this is while
you were going through recovery learning
to walk and all of that again really
that's kind of cool because it was kind
of like a light at the end of the tunnel
of like man okay I got this project I'm
he's a huge impetus to learn how to walk
again Wow I can't imagine that you know
I don't want people think about strokes
they think of old people
it can happen anyone know
so I was 48 when it happened yeah that
shaped my life like low cholesterol low
blood pressure Suze really use one of
these out of the blue things like you
just never know yeah so you've been you
know you've had this craft your whole
life and you had to kind of relearn to
do think what was your first day back
like actually the technical first day
back was on psych the movie - lassie
come home yeah don't applaud so that was
really just odd
get back to unset where I've been doing
this thing my entire life and it's like
muscle memory and suddenly this muscles
are gone yeah so I quickly learned that
Kemp couldn't memorize lines as quickly
as I did
so is it like harder then going back or
was it kind of fun and exciting because
it's you know this so well yeah deep in
you you know innately in fact on psych
theyyam it's such an amazing group of
people yeah Kastner producers they
rewrote the movie to really mirror much
like this what's going on with me
physically yeah sir lassie gets boiler
like shock shawn has a stroke on the
operating table Wow so the whole movies
me in recovery I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this